[Music]
hi there evan here on my technical
curriculum developer for google cloud
and high for me Jenny I'm a sales
trainer for Google cloud on an earlier
episode we looked at how Google bigquery
can IP get meaningful insights from your
data the hands-on labs also gave you a
chance to use the web UI and the
command-line tool to query public tables
and load in a sample of that data into
bigquery you can check out our link to
that episode here on this episode though
we're appealing to the basketball lovers
out there through a hands-on lab you're
going to use bigquery to explore the
NCAA dataset of basketball games teams
and players the game data covers
play-by-play and box scores back to 2009
as well as final scores back to 1996 but
if you love your data more than you love
basketball
that's fine too it isn't a coincidence
that this lab is based on n-c-double-a
data as part of its journey to the cloud
the NCAA is migrating over 80 years of
historical and play-by-play data from
ninety championships and 24 sports at
Google cloud we're extremely proud and
excited to be the official public cloud
provider of the n-c-double-a check out
the link to see how the n-c-double-a is
using Google cloud to tap into decades
of sports data with 100 thousand dollars
up for grabs Google Cloud n-c-double-a
and Kaggle teamed up for a unique
competition using the NCAA March Madness
tournament as the common backdrop
participants strengthened their
knowledge of basketball statistics data
modeling and cloud technology while
competing against each other for the
most innovative applications of machine
learning check out this link for the
blog post
now before we dive into the world of
basketball let's do a quick recap of
bigquery bigquery is a fully managed
massive scale low-cost enterprise data
warehouse running on top of Google's
proven compute storage and networking
infrastructure this allows you to focus
less on developing your infrastructure
and more on finding insights from your
data it's super fast to scanning
terabytes in seconds and even petabytes
and minutes this makes interactive
self-service exploration of massive
datasets viable which means better
analysis more creativity and you can
derive more interesting insights so now
for the fun bit quick labs in this
hands-on lab you're going to run a bunch
of cool queries against the n-c-double-a
dataset using bigquery some of the
results might just surprise you now you
can check out the link to start the
quick lab here and keep in mind it's
gonna take you about 45 minutes to
complete now so far the lab we found the
n-c-double-a public dataset in bigquery
we then preview the n-c-double-a immense
play-by-play table we create a query to
find the types of basketball plays we
run some fun queries including funding
which teams scored the most points in a
game here we find out which 10 teams
scored the most points cumulatively
since 2010 we also run some more complex
queries to determine which conferences
are the best at winning tight games we
hope you enjoyed this episode and add
some fun analyzing the NCAA data sub
we'd love to hear how Google bigquery
has helped you gain insights into your
own data sets - if you haven't signed up
for the $300 free trial credit on GCP
check out this link it's a great way to
apply what you've learned all of our
additional training resources are linked
below thanks again for watching and
we'll see you again soon check out our
episode on building a slack bot using
the vodka toolkit and running it on
Google cloud platform what's the video
and the quick lab demo here